c'est l'indignation encore une fois
l'unesco qualifie même de crime de
guerre la destruction d'un des plus
célèbres temples de la cité antique de
palmyre
c'est en syrie destruction orchestrée
par le groupe armé état islamique avait
réussi à arracher aux forces syriennes
cette ville antique il y a trois mois
pour un bon soir donc ce temple de
palmyre c'est tout un pan de l'histoire
du monde antique là qui disparaît c'est
un gros morceau du patrimoine culturel
mondial en fait céline s'était construit
en lan 17 donc ça fait presque deux
mille ans déjà que c'était sur pied
c'était quand même garder relativement
bien dans un un état assez incroyable vu
le temps qui a passé à 150 mille
personnes qui se déplacent et chaque
année pour aller voir cet endroit là
avant évidemment qui éclate le conflit
en syrie c'est un chef-d'oeuvre vivement
évidemment- architecture bon gréco
romaine et on parle encore une fois de
pamir ce mois-ci rappelez-vous les
quelques semaines on avait appris que le
directeur du site de palmyre avait été
capturé on a appris aujourd'hui en fait
qu'ils l'avaient été avant des décapités
par l'état islamique qu'il avait été
torturé
probablement pour lui soutirer de
l'information à savoir où est ce que on
pourrait trouver d'autres artefacts de
ce style là bon évidemment ce saccage ce
n'est que le dernier épisode d'une
longue liste de monuments qui ont été
détruits tout ce qui est prêt et cela me
qu'en fait les détruit sur le territoire
de l'état exactement donc palmyre c'est
le reste le plus récent événement on va
dire mais si on retourne en quelques
mois en arrière en fait il y avait aussi
le site historique de nemrod cette fois
ci en irak qui a vraiment été détruit à
coups de pioche de bulldozer également
mais d'explosifs non loin de là y'avait
aussi l'autre s'il notre site de atra là
aussi on a vraiment détruit des
sculptures des statuts vraiment qu'il y
avait un poids historique énorme
et puis aussi un peu plus tôt cette
année à mossoul la rappelez vous le
fameux saccage de la bibliothèque et du
musée de mossoul en irak
on avait vraiment vu les islamistes qui
brisés à coups de marteaux les shader
historique et si on s'arrête sur les
motivations évidemment on parle de tout
ce qui précise lamy qui l'idolâtrent y
donc c'est ce que dit l'état islamique
mais il ya plus que ça il ya plus que ça
en fait effectivement d'abord on veut
essayez d'enlever tout ce qui n'est pas
islamique la de l'histoire donc on
détruit ses morceaux là pour être sûr
que finalement les gens ne vont pas vous
est encore un attrait une certaine
idolâtrie mais aussi tout l'aspect dont
on va dire de l'argent qu'on peut tirer
de la vente de ce qui est pillé dans ses
musées parce qu'il faut pas se leurrer
ce le groupe etat islamique aussi en
profiter exactement en fait ils en
profitent pour vendre ça sur le marché
noir pour aller chercher peut-être des
centaines de milliers de dollars pour
justement financer d'autres opérations
de terreur et donc on voit ça là depuis
des mois maintenant ils continuent de
faire les exactions épouvantable et des
massacres qui se perpétue de semaine en
semaine donc on le voit c'est pas près
de finir malheureusement de la pince à
l'italie va en faire exactement
l'afghanistan avec les fameux bouddhas
de bamyan mais c'est aussi la même chose
au mali les islamique font aussi la même
chose là bas très bien merci beaucoup
frédéric calenge rue